hello everybody welcome to h3 podcast i
am here today with the hilarious andrew
santino
hey dude we shot this
after we shot the whole podcast because
yeah
it's uh because we just got right into
it in fact
this was fun yeah it was fun this intro
we do we need this intro dan
[Music]
it's gonna be really weird if we don't
uh do something how about i do an intro
ready
go ahead up welcome back to the h3
podcast
i'm ethan my guest today is andrew
santino a hilarious sexy funny cool
comedian
you're gonna love this guy he's on only
fans and we're gonna put up the link
below
all right all right good andrew how are
you today
by the way this is me with the mountain
from game of thrones you know that guy
i can't see i don't have proof oh yeah
of course dude is he is well
are you super tall how tall are six i'm
almost six two i'm 6-1 and some change
yeah so yeah wow yeah he's not that he's
not that tall but he's [ __ ] i mean
look he's the
yeah you know the strongest man in the
world apparently in the world yeah yeah
as if he could crush your head with his
bare hands if you wanted to
yeah you know and honestly like i'm in
character here i don't know here let me
you can see i played this like russian
character that's like a custom made suit
by this guy sarah who's this like famous
russian suit maker here in the valley in
la and um like he knew we were doing a
character show
and he got [ __ ] so mad at one point
because i wouldn't
take the workout serious like i'm in his
private gym
this sign says uh no arm and yar means
no [ __ ]
uh oh wow yeah he's uh in reykjavik
and that excludes you does that exclude
you or
no no he let me in he had to take down
the sign when i came in just for that
moment
okay good but he but he um he got so
[ __ ] mad because i didn't take out
the workout seriously and then when we
ate lunch he wouldn't talk to me because
he was like upset
wait hold on the mountain wouldn't talk
to you yeah he didn't like look me in
the eye when we ate lunch because he was
mad that i didn't do the workouts the
right way
wow you should have fought [ __ ] that guy
no dude honestly i thought about
fighting this [ __ ] i looked him
right in the eye and i said finish your
chicken [ __ ]
we're gonna [ __ ] scrap you know big
piece of [ __ ]
yeah you know i'm you're like a pretty
big it seems like you're a pretty big
muscular guy i feel like
most men could destroy me in a fight but
there's something
just like when you're next to a dude
like that you're like oh this guy would
literally just crush my skull
i mean yeah it's it's intimidating it's
actually it actually makes you feel um
it's emasculating it is fortunate it is
so so he's got to feel like
imagine how he feels i wonder if he just
thinks to himself i could kill this dude
like to everybody i think anytime
somebody like upsets him a little bit
i'm sure his first instinct is
i could just [ __ ] kill this guy right
here yeah no one would say anything yeah
nobody
that's gotta feel really good well and
we have a super small wife too yeah dude
she's that's so funny she's like
five one maybe maybe a hundred pounds
she's crazy tiny fantastic she by the
way she by the way was very very nice
and cool to us and like gave us all the
tips about
um like where to go in iceland and like
all the cool little like hidden spot
she was like really she was cool he just
was i think he was
for someone that didn't um that's used
to being on camera and game of thrones
he was extremely shy to the crew like
very like
it was it was interesting i just think
he's probably good when he has to act
like this
this you know monolithic mammoth man
strong man but like when it's just
us being human i think it was a little
weird it was weird for him i think it
was a little like
i don't know what to do or to say but he
was nice but
yeah his wife was cool they showed us
like all the legit low-key places that
you can go to
and why were you there uh why did you go
there
filming that show so that was like it
was like yahoo gave me some money to
create this character
this guy nikolai popoff i created this
character based on a real story there
was a um
in the 90s there was this olympic diver
who was like slotted to be like one of
the greatest of all time
he goes back to moscow with his brother
who's like his kind of his trainer best
friend partner in crime
business manager at all and they're
walking the streets of moscow
celebrating his last
win which would take him to the olympic
trials and he like crushed the
competition
um i can send you the article it's
insane they're walking the streets he
got in he got into a fight with a street
vendor
who ripped him off like they were drunk
and they were getting street food and
the street vendor
ripped him off and they went back in
front of him and the street vendor
[ __ ] stabbed this dude
and it debilitated him he could never
swim again like he cut something
vital and um long story short his
brother then would go on to try to like
train
other um olympians or whatever and he
became this kind of hack
joke of the business because it's like
yeah go with him you're gonna get
[ __ ] stabbed in the street on a
tuesday
so that was the birth of this nikolai
popoff this failed
olympic trainer and we would go around
meeting athletes and interviewing them
we did 10 episodes i think or eight
episodes
dude it was so much fun because i got to
stay in character we did like
i don't know if you like how much you
love pro sports this is a show that's
out now
no it's no no dude so yahoo had this
company that they paired with called go
90. it was like it was like yeah i
remember that yeah
yeah and they died or some [ __ ] yeah
that's right yeah
and so they we did it with them and they
like barely aired it because the company
was
like literally when we did our
deliverables like we turned in the
episodes
um the company [ __ ] went under and
they were like thank you
but uh yeah we got enough i mean we got
we got paid and we had a good time with
these dudes that i love producing with
so
it was fun as [ __ ] but like yeah it
wasn't gonna
what i don't know what to do with it now
you know what i mean you have to be
reshot and everything and
no it's just okay we'll [ __ ] you god
bless
yeah we got the money papa but hey
andrew before we get too deep into this
yeah there's something pressing that i
need to bring up to you
can you go ahead and pull up the wiki
feed page please ian
um do you know about wikifeet yeah dude
you know what's funny me and bobby on
on our show we were looking us up and i
couldn't find me on
wiki feet but it's you have to go to
wiki feet men i heard somebody else
yes that's where we spent our time i
know i didn't know i thought it was i
thought i'd make wikifeed well you
oh yeah you probably know you have a
pretty good score
i've heard i've had a pretty good score
that's [ __ ]
god those are old photos too well
basically they'll find any photo of your
foot
like if you have a new photo of your
foot it'll come up here like these
people
are next [ __ ] level
i want to knock can i knock something
out before we continue on yes
so but i i knew of you and i didn't
um i didn't know enough about you um
and i was talking to my friends on
history
and i don't you have a tick right you
have a tick yes i have
yeah i have a lot yeah so i didn't know
right
and i had and i had just because i had
seen your show and not really noticed it
in the weirdest way and then
on when burr came on i feel like the
clip is
the clips i saw like he was kind of burr
was heavy on the show he was a little
like aggro on your show it's kind of
like what happened with him and theo
yes and i know you guys you guys
acknowledged it and um
i was like man he's making ethan so
[ __ ] nervous he's like
he's like he's like squinting a lot and
i was talking about it on history hyenas
and then a bunch of people hit me up and
were like
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] you don't know
dude and people were lighting me up and
i had no idea and i was like oh
now i kind of feel bad i wasn't like
mocking it but i was like dude he looks
so
nervous against burr but truth be told
it did it was nerve-wracking it's
he's never he's the worst he like ruined
my whole [ __ ] year
like but he was nice you know what he
was so nice
he came back on and we had a good a good
second episode yeah the makeup i saw
yeah yeah but the
thing is you on youtube people are so
vicious
and [ __ ] just they're the worst right
so
it was awkward sure yeah i mean it was
just brutal but then like everybody in
the ecosystem made it so much worse
i mean welcome to the [ __ ] to the
internet but anyway i wanted to say that
to you because
well it's fine you know i did hold a
grudge i saw that and i and i
was it was down my list to confront you
i was gonna i was gonna take your name
off my
my uh hit list okay thanks dude
thank you very much where's your where's
your beautiful wife by the way
uh well she was offended too so she just
couldn't face you
no she she's working she has she has a
we have a clothing company
and she she's the uh the big dog
so she's got i got it she can't join us
every day anymore
no that's good also by the way your um
uh trish or whatever the the
yeah trish is um
trista's your your battle with trish
with her race or with her anti-semitism
is uh is forever my favorite thing so
thank you man
that's you're really fighting the good
fight there and uh genuinely i don't
think she's anti-semitic but
um she's good at faking it you know what
i mean like well it's
it's weird because most people who are
obsessed with jews
don't like them she might be yeah so
it's hard to
kind of com it's hard to really
rationalize that
because she's in love with the jewish
man yeah yeah no i think but also
hitler was hitler's wife was jewish so
you know you know what i'm saying
no ava braun was jewish no don't no that
i how do i not know that
google that fact checked that ian ava
braun he
listened to the last name ava braun was
jewish lebron is just a german
that just means brown a jewish german
name dude
[Laughter]
right yeah hitler had a hitler had a
jewish dog he had
um his dog was a bar mitzvah yep a bark
mitzvah
he had a mark you know that's a real
thing no shut up i swear to god pull it
up ian
i did a whole video about it it's a bark
mitzvah dude
honestly did you have a cool bar mitzvah
video like i have so many friends ahead
like uh
you know people do like videos for their
bar mitzvah they either do like
songs to invite people to them and [ __ ]
have you ever seen these
yes i have um did you do one the thing
is no i did not i feel like i'm i'm old
now i'm old enough like i'm 35 so when i
got bar mitzvah
it was kind of before the tech
revolution i
like to think that i wouldn't do that
though i mean there's this one video
uh the bar mitzvah song where he's
having a pool party do you recall that
one
pull that one up ian pull it up pull
it off just just to chime in real quick
i googled the uh
ava brown thing and yeah it was a few
years ago they did a dna
dna test on uh her hair brush and uh
sure enough she has jewish hands
straight so she may have not been like
totally jewish so were you referring to
the hair brush dna
yeah that just came out a couple years
ago yeah
wow that's crazy he was a sure
yeah that's actually his that was his
license plate
[ __ ] both he's like you know if i'm
gonna [ __ ] him his license plate was
fkr and they let him get away with it
nowadays they check that stuff you know
if there's any cuss words but yeah and
his
other card was her too squared
go ahead and play the bark mitzvah just
to prove to andrew that this is real
mickey this is a very joyous occasion
for you
who's 100 years old two centuries my god
all right he's gonna help me oversee the
[ __ ] mitzvah with you it was muzzle tub
all around for a special dog called
nikki
the pomeranian pooch celebrate today
bark mitzvah
for turning two or three oily
the event is one of the latest races in
dog lover circles
a booming multi-million dollar industry
what year was it
all right thank you this is a boom by
the way a booming 10 million dollar
industry they said yeah dude we should
get into that
like what year was that on was that you
can tell that was before the world
started burning because people were oh
yeah
the associated press was like just do a
[ __ ] bark mitzvah video
right yeah no it looks like it's from
the
90s it looks old as [ __ ] i got my
i got invited uh to a bar mitzvah
um when i was a kid when i was living in
chicago and it was in
this really nice high rise this my
friend uh my friend jacobs
bar mitzvah and um uh never in my life
have i felt so
um left out because everyone
had assumed i was jewish and then and
then he kind of embarrassed me
in front of he was like he's not jewish
look at him and they all looked at me
and then
um i felt really depressed so that's why
i have beef with jews dude forever okay
good
i was wondering where that was going
yeah i would never assume
yeah you look like an irish what do they
call it a white
a whap or no not sorry that's a wet ass
[ __ ] what do they call that
damn the uh wasp are you talking about
wasp yeah white
but irishes are usually catholic so they
want to be a wasp yeah i don't know that
much about all that
are you catholic no i mean when i was a
kid i guess
um but you know we don't hold on to
religion my people we let
like irish people they're like we're
we're bad
we're bad catholics i guess because we
don't obey any of that [ __ ] we don't
really go along with it
i mean my fam my parents got divorced
when i was one so
my mom we you can't be divorced in the
catholic church anyway
so we weren't religious yeah it's a big
no-no you have to get your marriage
annulled
basically saying to the church it never
existed in order to like stay in the
church and
that's [ __ ] you have to pretend like
it never happened
well that's a that's a real thing
literally
these guys are such dicks man it's like
just [ __ ] loosen
up no dude you know what i mean and
that's that's what they say to the altar
boys loosen up but i do
think that that's so bad got him
while you were quick on that one it's um
no it's no i was never really religious
dude honestly i never
but i but i don't look at to be truthful
with you
there's a lot of redheaded hasidic jews
in my [ __ ] neighborhood so you're
wrong
they don't look like you though trust me
i lived in israel no they
don't oh you lived in israel dude we've
all lived
in israel for a short amount of time
you're not specially
okay i lived in israel for three and a
half months it's not that i i live there
too all right
you think i didn't go on birthright you
just say you're jewish yeah
that's you know that's true people on my
birthright group
they're like oh i'm not even jewish yeah
i was like whoa
crazy i wish i [ __ ] knew i would have
done that because they didn't give you
like a dna test or anything
well i think me don't you think if i did
go down the line they'd be like i don't
know
man no you could sell it
because i could because right though
like um your mother just has to be
jewish so my dad could be a big irish
[ __ ] and my mom could be jewish and i
just look like my dad right you
literally just have to say yeah my mom's
jewish
and uh yeah and that's it yeah that's
great it's pretty
it's pretty nice you want to talk about
some current events
yeah yes i want to do whatever i want to
talk about whatever the painting behind
you is really dope by the way oh
yeah thank you um a friend of ours
oliver tree he's a musician
yeah i know him i mean i know we do well
apparently his little brother painted
that for us i don't really know
what's true with him ever yeah he could
have outsourced it to china for all
probably yeah
you know they'll they'll make anything
for you like you know they'll make art
for you in china you can like just
they're crazy over there where do you
think all this stuff came from
this is all china behind me actually
actually this is a japanese guy kasuke
miyagi who drew me and bobby like that
these great drawings so
i'm i'm more japan over china i'm more
of a japanese guy so
i i get china is cool but i think japan
is better but
you do as you please you know what i
mean whatever you like more you know
well in terms of um in terms of war
crimes the japanese
well see it's kind of a tough call
because like back world war
ii japan was king of the uh war crime
the chinese don't like but now china is
kind of inching up
in the water they're creeping up there
they're doing really yeah with the
muslim population there i mean they're
straight up putting them in
concentration camps so
millions of them so that's so they're
doing good honestly
power ratings all around they're trying
to rank
all right what's up what are we uh
what's the current event by the way um i
love uh
i love zach's uh guitar setup back there
it looks good zach
oh thank you very much i like that
hanging on the wall
that doesn't look earthquake proof by
the way so
we had a quake a few days ago and uh i
was scared
i'm scared shitless i'm not gonna lie
did you do you ever think about those
things breaking and then [ __ ] tons of
money going out the window because
you've hung them on the wall
well yeah but those are kind of my
beater guitars my better guitars are on
like the floor
in the cases okay fancy guys someone's
getting paid too much ethan
yeah you're right my beater guitars he
has five beater guitars on the wall
that's good all right dude's obsessed
yeah collections at like 11 so why why
do you need 11
i don't get that i don't get i don't get
i don't understand guitar people they're
like yeah
but you know you just play like one of
them or maybe two of them you don't play
11 guitars
i actually i actually do i mean there's
different sounds like you have a fender
strat or
you want to go more for like all right
[Music]
i'm not getting started about talking
about all the different by the way i
would the first
the only one i know is a fender
stratocaster so i could have even said
that so you might be a liar dude he
might not play guitar
you know what i'm not going to give you
the air time to prove that you're not
yeah don't don't do it don't you want to
talk about ellen
yeah i saw i saw what she
so she did dude let's see let me just
let's see she came back
uh she said blah blah blah yadda yadda
let's watch the clip pull it up again
let's just watch it and then we can
trash that
nice lady oh boy
i didn't say anything no you didn't
degenerate
[Applause]
by the way ellen tube sounds like porn
just straight up ellentube
that's where i come to beat off dude
yeah
if you're watching because you love me
thank you if you're watching because you
don't love me
welcome
by the way she's like 65 years old so
you know
she's like applying baby foreskin to her
face or something because
they do placenta they have baby placenta
that they rub all over it's wild i've
actually been
have access to some and i have to dole
it out i only do you have access
well you may think i'm kidding but
actually there is a procedure
that sandra bullock was telling ellen
about and this is true
and i swear to god korean baby foreskin
facial not kidding oh really the
foreskin
of korean children specifically koreans
not
why why koreans i wonder i think they
just are down to sell it
ellen um the i think the most surprising
thing about that clip and i watched it
we obviously don't have to see the whole
i think a lot of people saw it but i
the most surprising thing for me was i
that she's gay i was a little thrown off
by quite frankly a little
i was like that's pretty bold to you
know you you get accused
of belittling your staff and treating
them poorly and then
now you use the opportunity to come out
as gay now it's like what a cover-up do
you know what i'm saying
he did that yeah just like i got like oh
by the way i'm gay it's like
okay that sounds like you're covering up
for all the mean stuff you did
why are you gay do you uh
do you do you believe that oh yeah
i had to show you this did you see the
virtual audience dude play this [ __ ]
go back a little bit so you can see hear
her introduce it it's
are they on tvs is that what that is bro
just look at this virtual audience here
instead
here you all are amount of applause
[Applause]
what the [ __ ] they're all on like flat
vertical flat screens that's awesome how
creepy is that
so do you think there's no way she
didn't know right that like people were
being molested and
berated there is it possible i think
what's possible
is i think she i think
i think ellen is so well i think when
you get that rich and that famous and
that powerful
i think when you're like at the top of
the building you just don't you stop
giving a [ __ ]
what's going on i think you just don't i
think they don't give a [ __ ] i think
they're like
oh what and they hear something and
someone's like well i gotta tell you
something someone
or that's not even brought to their
attention half the time and i think they
don't give a [ __ ]
i genuinely think she's so far removed
from the process
i think she couldn't care less though if
someone was like if she probably heard
or if someone at that power level hears
someone belittling an intern or saying
something [ __ ] up
it doesn't even strike a chord with them
you know what i mean i think they're
just like whatever dude i'm doing 15
other things
if someone hears someone being like you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're supposed to get
this done
you [ __ ] dumb piece of [ __ ]
belittling but what i don't think they
have time to care i don't think they
have the time to balance so
genuinely you know we're giving her a
pass on this one
not a pass i just don't think they i
don't think they [ __ ] i think
anyone at that level never gives a [ __ ]
i just can't imagine that they can
i don't think they care i think they
just they're they're worried about
whatever wealth aspects are going on in
their world about like what
you know what a vacation you're gonna
take or what [ __ ] what room you're
gonna decorate next i think when you
become so wealthy you start you stop
thinking about people as people
and they're just like little entities
near you i think that's
my experience with very very wealthy
people it just kind of feels like
um like there's a guy i know who's
[ __ ] very well off and he's very nice
you know he's a nice guy to me but like
i see how he interacts with people now
and he treats them almost if like
they're all um
they're all there for a thing to service
him like you're a good this so you do
that well around me and you're a good
that
and that's that's the only thing they
service it's really interesting i wonder
if it's just like a defense mechanism
because
it's just so like a survival instinct
why it's just so odd to be that
to be like a billionaire you know she's
probably almost a billionaire i don't
know how much money she's
got to be [ __ ] close without i mean i
mean i have her bed sheets i have ellen
sheets and ellen close at the house
i support it you know i support her so
yeah i think the whole thing is [ __ ]
i think
the other [ __ ] up thing is um
you know like that people act like our
business
um is wholesome anyway and you're like
have you not read any of the [ __ ] new
like we've all
this has always been a tyrannical place
they used to own actors they literally
made you contract in the 40s to be like
we own you if you go do anything else
we'll [ __ ] be
we'll we'll um you know abolish you from
the business you won't be welcome
so they treated people in the business
for [ __ ] like years that's what the
platform
that this business was built on was like
you always are answering to somebody
and they always treat you rank and file
it's like the [ __ ] military so
when something [ __ ] up happens like
this like an abuse of power treating
people poorly you're like
how could you be surprised it's not even
close to being the first time we've seen
you think this is never it's just it's
kind of like [ __ ] it's like
you know par for the course or whatever
it's like yeah it's like i'm never
surprised
if you told me that she was running a
[ __ ] a baby
foreskin uh uh [ __ ] you know
force foreskin a forced four skin uh
enslavement camp i'd be like
damn that's wild but also like yeah i
guess that makes sense if there's good
money
i'm not totally surprised by that no
it wouldn't throw yeah you know i mean
yeah i mean what are the accusations
they're like oh people were mean
and bullying oh but then there was
sexual misconduct about one of our
producers was like kept grabbing dick
and but like i mean you know that's by
the way go to west hollywood once go to
go to west hollywood once you're gonna
get your dick grabbed all the [ __ ]
time yeah
and those are all everyone that's all
ellen producers down at
uh she's got a lot of producers for a
lot of producers
big show big show dude yeah big joe
the other one okay so you heard it from
andrew he's giving ellen a
pass i'm giving her i'm giving her the
yup saw it coming
yeah so i'd comment the other one i want
to ask
you about carol baskin competing with
dancing with the stars
yeah carol bat and that there's another
wrinkle to this which is fascinating
okay she came on the show
and i don't know how familiar you are
with her story
very yeah she was the woman and tiger
king who
uh was the the arch nemesis
of uh li tiger joe is that his
name joe exotic tiger joe i like tiger
joe
it's more white trash and more becoming
of him anyway
um he
he and many allege that carol baskin
killed her first husband
and during the airing of the first
episode
her first husband ran an ad
accusing her of murdering their dad
yeah that is [ __ ] amazing
let's run this out okay let's see it i
want to see this
the dancing itself was really whatever i
mean she's an old lady trying to dance
it's the fact that did we have her on
is kind of kind of insane
i mean she's like it's like having oj on
kind of
yeah dude oj oj still gets a lot of
sponsorships like people haven't stopped
you know what i mean like he dates
imagine dating o.j bro but let's be real
if you were a young girl and you're on
raya or one of these dating apps and you
see oj on there don't you kinda
like the mystique you're like what if he
[ __ ] kills me that's why women like
that's why women like to get choked in
bed some women love to be choked you
know because they like the
a woman said this to me one time a woman
fred said i said she goes i love being
choked i said why she goes because of
the fear i was like oh
because of the fear i swear to god she
said because of the fear so
i'm sure there's women why do you think
women date [ __ ] inmates why do you
why do you think that well you're right
they like the idea of oh this guy could
maybe kill me and it's kind of sexy
yeah but like they don't but with oj you
it's like
yeah no i i will actually but you know
what i mean i just
no see i think i think he's not if you
were a woman dating o.j
knowing that he had such a little strike
twice kind of thing
yeah you're not gonna he his his first
murder was so messy it's like if he's
gonna do it again first of all he'd be
cleaner about it so he'd go about it in
a better way if he was gonna kill you
and then
also you know i think i yeah you don't
want some like
stabbed in the yard is crazy you know
what i mean you're bleeding outside of
your house
he would do something a little bit more
tidy
you know like pills or you know
something cool like that i think so but
i just
yeah i know but it's sexy
it's sexy to know that he might kill you
well i think we should have a dancing
the stars with
o.j uh charles manson is still alive
right in prison
no didn't he finally die oh they just
died he died oh man
rest in peace to a great one oj woody
allen
cosby he's still kicking he can get his
s out there
yeah he can cosby woody allen
oj um there's so many star-studded
people that could be on uh dancing with
the stars i actually oh
mel gibson would i mean he would crush
yeah does he still hate jews is that uh
come on you don't just shed that
dude do you remember
years ago i did years ago i mean i i
hated you from the time i was
i told you from the bar mitzvah when i
was 10 until i was 15 and i finally let
it go
i finally let it go well no okay please
remember his famous quote
what was it i hope you get raped by a
pack
of n-words he said to his wife
and he made that a famous he he made
that a famous line
i remember hearing that all the time
when i was when i was younger when that
first came
out okay let's analyze it maybe he's
into the cuckery of it all maybe he
thinks that's hot
[Music]
well what if that turns him off the tone
was certainly
i don't know man you don't know how
people talk in their bedroom that could
have been a really
just before he's like listen i hope you
make a showcase on black
dot com which is a real website black
raw black raw black rose
oh black draw what's the difference
between black raw and black one of them
has a condom and the other one doesn't
you know
oh [ __ ] why do they need a separate
website for black draw
because it's a sub category no they it's
like their umbrella
black is the black is the mother ship
black if black
is ellen black raw is ellen's boutique
clothing line at target well i mean just
not to split hairs here but if you're
watching black
dot com you probably want to go straight
to black raw
no dude some people are into safety some
people like the idea of sex with a
condom
i have a lot of friends that will only
watch condom porn because they're
worried for the actors that they're like
i don't
i don't want to watch someone catch
anything yeah you guys want to watch
this ad
that's vin diesel by the way yeah pull
up that ad in if you would please
thank you god bless you appreciate you
god bless you god bless you you're the
best
i'm gail one of don lewis's daughters
we are a real family and to us he was
daddy
i'm linda one of don lewis's daughters
and we miss
our dad i'm donna i'm don lewis's oldest
daughter
we need to know what happened to our
father
i'm anne don's former assistant hold on
assistant
why is she included she has no right to
be here
they have just a woman coming she's like
um i am consuela i cleaned the house for
dawn
for 12 years and this i don't know what
this is but
[Laughter]
i lost my job i also miss don
like what the [ __ ] is assistant let's
keep watching
that surprised me justice for dawn
don lewis mysteriously disappeared
[Music]
five
carol yeah just uh we should have all
your fans just call in and just say it
was carol it was carol baskin she's on
this
carol basketball she's gonna get away
with it because she's heir to the baskin
the the baskin robbins family money
that's where all her [ __ ] money comes
from
baskin robbins the ice cream company
that's her family that you're lying
about
no dude google it she got her money from
her ex that's why she killed him
baskin robbins ethan she's the baskin in
basketball
steven robbins and carol baskin's family
baskin robbins
ian can look it up if you need him too
listen we don't spread misinformation on
this show
that's a great quote
so that's pretty amazing i bet she
didn't see that coming i wonder if she
would have agreed if knowing that
she's she's gonna get away with it
because now
the media is so good at making you
either
the victim or this like lovable creature
and they made her this lovable character
like that that documentary made her out
to be like
even though they tried to play that side
we're like what could have happened they
still wanted to make her this
you know like a mistreated
[ __ ] animal hero it's like you can't
you're gonna play on the heartstrings of
animal lovers she's never gonna
they're never gonna get her dude they're
never gonna get her well apparently the
rumor is she
grinded him under the well whatever she
did his body is long gone so
yeah it's like if that once the media's
painted you with somebody they love it
doesn't matter like they found out
[ __ ] clinton went on epstein's plane
26 times it doesn't matter
that's crazy isn't it that it's a fact
it's crazy that it's a [ __ ] literal
logged
pilot logged fact that he went there 26
times and people are like
whatever it's like what i'm trying i
tried to rationalize it in a way that
it's like
okay good luck he he he was on epstein's
plane 26 times what is the chance he
didn't [ __ ] a little girl
okay let's let's say this even if he
just liked going to the island
there's lots of [ __ ] islands did he
go to the island for sure
there's proof that he went to the island
oh well actually no there was that
anecdote that recently came out of like
a gardener or someone or
an architect oh [ __ ] it's bill clinton
playing a saxophone for a bunch of 14
year olds i just can't believe that all
these people are just down to
like [ __ ] little girls well let's let's
say this let's just say he wasn't
involved in the sexual activity
he wanted more of the business aspect
and the power aspect like i said about
the ellen thing like they don't really
care what's going on around them as long
as they're getting what they need
so i imagine he's getting something else
out of it business-wise right like he's
getting
there's got to be people there that go
there to help him get what he needs
politically and business-wise
whatever that may be because the [ __ ]
that
that group of lizard people illuminati
[ __ ] is
they're planning their futures futures
futures when they go to those islands
like
it's like we think about money now you
know like your wife is running your
business
your your cute little business compared
to these rich but you know what i mean
like
our money is pales in comparison to what
these people have access to so
they're exchanging billions of dollars
in futures so
i heard this stat elon musk is closer to
being
dead broke zero dollars homeless
than he is to being jeff bezos
no way yeah no way
that's [ __ ] insane well jeff bezos is
worth almost 200 billion now although
this
the stock market went down a bit lately
so it it's crazy a bad a bad stock day
affects his net worth by like 10 billion
dollars well they said right he made he
made the biggest
amazon made the biggest first quarter
they've ever made in history of the
company during the pandemic
yeah that's [ __ ] twisted isn't it
it's [ __ ] well honestly
how many packages do you guys get to
your house from amazon dude it's a joke
i have piles of boxes outside my house
the problem with amazon is that
their service is just too [ __ ]
superior to anybody else
yeah dude it's there i ordered it it's
there i needed a cord for my computer it
was at my house the next morning
i'm not going to [ __ ] best buy and
talking to some
[ __ ] yeah uh you want a uc
usbc converter and i don't know i don't
know if we have
let me see if we have those one second
you don't need to do that yeah you can
just click click click click click it's
at my [ __ ] door
it's it's become um the convenience
level is almost
it's almost it's almost scary it's just
like there's no
yeah and now they're building grocery
stores right like the first one in the
country is in woodland hills
in our next woods seriously and yeah
first one in the country
and what you do is you just walk in
apparently you just like somehow i
haven't been there this was
my my dad told me he was there you s you
it's all a bunch of bar codes
you take it off the shelf put in your
cart and it automatically knows
so you don't have to go to a register
you don't have to [ __ ] pay you
literally
take the [ __ ] and leave so they so they
actually the first run of this was in
manhattan they actually didn't
they did this store the the the test run
or whatever
was in manhattan they wanted to see if
it could actually work if you could get
people to walk in and do it
and you can look up the article i think
it failed miserably because
the lack of control of how many people
they just couldn't control how many
people were coming and going
because what it does is it tracks via i
think it was tracking via your app you
have to have like the amazon
app and then it tracks via your pinning
of your phone location services to what
you're taking with you but i think the
one in manhattan or
i think it was yeah it had been managed
but it but it [ __ ] up and failed
because it just
how can you control that much foot
traffic yeah manhattan's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
joke because
i'm sure it was like tiny and tons of
people
yeah i mean it you know yeah manhattan's
a [ __ ] night it sunk over the weekend
i don't know if you guys saw that on the
news
in the underwater oh [ __ ]
yeah it's like a mistake dude well but
good there's so many buildings that a
lot of people
a lot of people are still above water
but now some people have underwater
views which i think the lower apartments
ironically are going to be worth more
than the higher apartments the mid
right right so if you have a water vapor
gondola gondola yeah
you say it how you want to say it don't
don't correct him you guys if he wants
to say gondola he can say that
i was i got it right eventually i mean i
was working my way there
what else do we have what's what does tf
stand for by the way what is the what
tf what does that stand for on your
house oh teddy fresh oh teddy fresh
it's our clothing company yes i know i
know i know i saw you had clothing beef
with somebody uh
yeah he's a james [ __ ] he said he
said what
it's not the same thing but i saw your
stuff but i'm not a fan so i didn't copy
you that's kind of what it was
well first he said it's totally
different because my pocket is yellow
i was like okay well no it's identical
and then he goes this was before the
collection came out
so then unprompted he goes oof actually
one of the colorways
which i hadn't yet seen he goes is
actually identical to yours
i'm gonna have to talk to my design team
about that
and then i never heard back and he's
selling the hoodie
is it his design team is just just a guy
that lives with him just like
i just copied it they're like oh okay
well that's where it came from
yeah he's like yeah yeah i mean exactly
so
yeah and he's so popular you know that
he's going to sell a billion of them
and uh it is what it is
so i mean that's what china does dude
china makes uh the best copies on earth
you know what i mean
well the thing is technically what he's
doing isn't
illegal what would be illegal is to
steal
our logo right because you can't
copyright the
you can't cut right you can't copyright
uh
a specific article of clothing right so
there's always people that rip you
off there's been people this is like our
most popular item on the right here
and you guys need to just write uh
brothers on yours
yeah just keep just keep combating
whatever he does
just do the exact opposite of it on
yours i mean
brotherhood would be great across yours
get rid of the teddy fresh and just say
brothers
in the exact same font because that
would be totally legal too i think you
just go back and forth
wait who is that person by the way i'm
very i don't know who that is he's a
makeup
he's like a makeup guru on youtube but
he's he's like
super [ __ ] popular sure makeup guru
that's a thing daddy i want to be a
makeup guru
when i get older good business man yeah
i'm sure it is i'm sure it's [ __ ]
tons of money and that's why
the country is burning is because we
have people that make 10 million a year
being makeup gurus we're done
we're keep going we deserve keep going
deserve it it's more than that
how much you how much does this person
make a year for real
20 million 20 maybe yeah that's why [ __ ]
off dude
shoot me now that's insane
can i be honest i am going to check them
out after because i do need i do need a
couple of rouge tips because every time
i do my rouge you can see it's uneven so
i do want to go check out his
yeah he's got good rouge tips yeah let
me ask you about this
this started a debate uh between all of
us here you said
on conan that you sleep naked
but you had this whole stigma about your
parents
when you were young saying you can't
sleep naked in case there's an emergency
or the house is on fire
because the house goes on fire yeah mine
was uh there'll be an
earthquake because i grew up in
california yeah in chicago we don't have
that
but that but i think you
there's other things for example um
these guys brought up you can't turn on
the light in the car did you ever be
told that
that that it's like a legal or something
the overhead light
yeah at night i've never heard that in
my life
we all got told we can't turn the
overhead light on in the car because
it's illegal
our parents all told us get pulled over
yeah why would it be why would it be
there then
exact question yeah i don't know if
every car manufacturer makes it if it
was illegal they would at some point
well you're a dumb kid
what was the reason why they didn't want
us to have it now it's probably just
annoying to them
they just lie and say it's illegal
you're like you're gonna get that's what
that's your whole childhood is your
parents
saying you that something is you can't
do it because it's annoying because when
you learn how to cross your eyes
and you're like dad dad he's like he's
like do that and you'll get stuck
it's a lie you know what i mean like
they lie about [ __ ] they lie about
everything to protect themselves like
for years right
my parents told me when i was a kid for
years that when i was a very young kid
they told me that santa claus wasn't
real
and then once you find out that he is
real you're like that's [ __ ] gross to
like lie to kids
right for that long like that's [ __ ]
up that's just a [ __ ] up thing so
you know i just i don't understand the
psyche behind that no my mother made a
promise
i've made a promise to myself i'm not
gonna lie i have a son now he's one
over just over one i let's see if i last
but i really think i don't want to lie
to him about this [ __ ] because it [ __ ]
you up because you hold it with you your
whole life
they make up this weird little lie
because you're annoying
and then you know fast forward 30 years
and you're walking around thinking like
that
turning your car light on is illegal
like one of our guys a b
he's like he's you know in his mid-20s
and he's like wait that's not illegal
like he literally you know but the
yeah this kind of [ __ ] you know it's
sticking with
your head ian can you pull up the um
my favorite video that i don't want to
even give it away dude is sitting in a
stall
dude is sitting in it oh i saw it oh
what the [ __ ]
why'd you see it yeah because i'm an
internet guy bro
but how do you even know what it is if
guys sitting at a stall that couldn't
possibly because it's guys hitting a
stall and a fight breaks out
that's not the video all right play it
how many videos would take place at a
stall oh i've seen it come on dude the
one i'm just talking about is amazing
but that video is amazing by the way
that's incredible
those kids are fighting that poor kid's
taking a [ __ ] and he's just covering up
his face
by the way i've been that guy i've been
the guy that when i was taking a [ __ ] in
junior high and i never [ __ ] at school i
always waited a [ __ ] at home
the door latched you know those old
[ __ ] door latches from school
they never [ __ ] worked and it
literally i watched it like a ghost
like a [ __ ] ghost unlatched
and the door those doors always swung
open they never stayed closed because of
the weight
it swung wide open and a dude that was
done pissing and goes to wash his hands
and eye to eye in the mirror i'm just
pooping
my little penis between my leg oh dude
it was the [ __ ] work and then i
haven't pooped in public again since
never ever never
ever ever i've never even had it an
emergency
no i leave if i've got a poop i gots to
go i gotta go
sometimes you can't hold it in yes you
can if you have patience
if you have patience and you have the
mental fortitude to hold in you can
pinch and hold
dude i've made it 37 years i think i
know what i'm [ __ ] doing i know
apparently
but i don't i don't think i have that uh
well you're more of a you're more of a
um you're more of like a loose guy i'm
more wound tight so i can keep my [ __ ]
high
i can i can move it up my sternum and i
can
log it up higher i can keep my poop up
here oh really you can store it up in
like your lungs
yes sir yes sir and what if you have
food poisoning or something i mean
sometimes you really just got to
[ __ ] your pants i mean so to speak i've
had food poisoning twice and both times
it's out the mouth
and throw up more than poop more than
poop and i think that's because i've
communicated to my body that i don't
want to [ __ ] up my poop cycle so i say
if you're going to come out so when i
did that food poisoning i was [ __ ]
and puking out of my mouth both came out
of my mouth
so wow that sounds that sounds dramatic
the body figures it out
ian let's show him the real and only
stall video on the internet please
go ahead roll it stall video
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
my friend now here's the question here's
the question we ask
who says sorry is it the guy
[ __ ] or is a guy on the floor all
right let's play
go ahead get one more look
[Music]
i have i know it's actually a third
party there's another guy that's not
no there's a third shooter there's a
third shooter
yeah it seems as if there was another
man involved too like watch how quickly
he gets up off the ground i imagine
there's a third man in there
who is holding him you know like tom
cruise when he came down on wire is a
mission impossible
his friend was lowering him down he's
excited i didn't realize too low and he
was too low and that's when he's like oh
[ __ ] he looks up and he's like sorry he
said sorry because he put him in let's
see
see how fast he gets lifted by his bud i
love that clip
that's so [ __ ] funny man also
yeah but i think no i think he just some
people like watching people poop i don't
even think it's
i think it's just it's able to see the
in a public place
yeah it's awesome what's wrong with
watching a human get rid of waste
well apparently you you had a problem
with it when the door swam open on you
here's the here's the deal with me if
you look at this if you think about
something at face value that seems gross
he's watching a man poop
if you think about the science of it
it's pretty incredible that we can
digest food take the nutrients we need
and we get rid of the waste so it's
really neat he might be a scientist
that's just like
it's cool to see i didn't see notepad
huh i didn't see a notepad real
scientists keep it up here but
because i'm and we're observers you're
just a public observer yeah that guy's
really cool to watch people poop is not
chill you guys at home don't do it but
also if you do
send in the video right you know right
right yeah good
oh you know that fart sound is uh wendy
williams
shut up i swear to god you remember when
she farted on the
on the program we isolated it and we
increased the audio
and she was saying oh it wasn't a fart
she went on like a whole taurus being
like oh i
remember this is that sound isolated i
swear to god
where to [ __ ] that's her ripping wow we
call her wendy williams now
wendy i remember when she farted or when
she fainted yeah that was it would have
it would have been dope if she fainted
and farted if she was like herself
but that's like the cleanest fart like
it's very obvious ever yeah
and it's not like pitched or anything
that's like the
exact audio from her [ __ ] straight
straight from her [ __ ] my friends
i would vote i would vote for her if she
ran for prez she seems like she'd be a
fun president don't you think
you wouldn't you wouldn't vote for a wen
diesel
he's partying actually entertaining the
idea right now
i know i see your brain doing it like it
could be funny
i would actually prefer her to uh to
trump
she i like her she would probably do
lots of of
briefings talking about gossip
yeah it'd be f it would be it would be
trump it would be another kind of trump
presidency but it would be way more fun
and involved
yeah really cool whoops she's like we're
doing a woopwoo rally in canton ohio
yeah and you you know you go to the
whoop rallies would be fun i don't know
what if we got
300 million people to all of the united
states whoop whooping at the same time
that would end the world i bet you i
think that would that would summon the
antichrist
[Laughter]
hey you used to work on punk right punk
was the first thing i ever did that was
like the first thing i did in los
angeles
what did you get that job like straight
straight bright-eyed or you already kind
of a reputable comedian
no dude not at all i mean what happened
was and um
i hate talking about it because it's my
[ __ ] past i don't really love it
[ __ ] it i don't no no no no but the good
story is i wrote a pilot with another
guy for comedy central and
in the and we did a i talked about this
on rogan a little bit but
it was probably the most fun time i ever
had was writing this like
unbridled prank show for this this dude
this the
the black dude from season one of punk
al sheer and we wrote some great [ __ ]
bits dude some really
fun bit like we did this bit called
gangster gardener where he went to
um bel bel-air with like three big jack
black dudes and they just started mowing
your lawn and like
taking care of your your landscaping and
people with these rich bel air people
would come out and be like what what the
[ __ ] and then he would just hand them a
bill and just be like yo play as
gangster gardener just show up
we show up we clean up we leave you know
we do it efficiently you know
and and the bit was so [ __ ] funny but
got so
race like so racist that comedy central
was like we can't air it i was like you
you have to [ __ ] air it like it was
so good
we can we gave people this we gave
people um
we gave people mayonnaise that we had
put brown food coloring in and we called
it melon and mayonnaise and we had him
pitch them
to a um test group and they eat the
sandwiches and then we showed him a
video
saying the mayonnaise they have actually
has melanin in it and they were going to
turn black like they would be black by
the afternoon
and if you saw the [ __ ] reaction i
mean people were like i don't want to be
black
i don't want to be black that's so funny
oh yeah
yeah yeah so that was what led to punk i
wrote we wrote this show me and me and
this comedian ian edwards who's
[ __ ] one of the funniest people on
earth and
um ian and i wrote wrote the show
together and then punk was like
do you want to write another season for
us and you know whatever and then i did
it
oh interesting i did it yeah that's kind
of how it worked out it was the same
studio that produced for
um for punk so they were like just come
right on this show because they're
so i i did that and then i guess get a
bunch of other [ __ ] [ __ ]
i guess my question was because i i
recall the story when
zack braff beat the [ __ ] out of some kid
on punk
oh yeah that was before my time oh wow
yeah okay because i was wondering if
that was before
if they ever cut [ __ ] that never made it
that was like that crazy
oh dude yeah i mean um you know like uh
um
why can't i think his name uh uh there's
a rapper who they did
on the season like the second of last
season
um he was busted somebody even busted
rhymes camp or something but they
stormed into the studios back when
you know like mtv was in trailer park in
hollywood with like guns and [ __ ] we're
like give up that [ __ ] tape
yeah because they look because they were
embarrassed about it it's probably
illegal to talk about it but i wasn't a
part of it so it was a rumor anyway
wow yeah this one is crazy
they were like give me the [ __ ] tape
i mean i have friends that used to
produce that show
in the heyday when like you know when
kanye [ __ ] freaked out and tried to
steal the footage back like i had
friends that produced those
seasons and um yeah it was a lot of fun
it was it was
it was heavy i mean that show you know
it was
it was [ __ ] up dude i mean it was the
first thing in hollywood that i did and
you know back then i was like yeah i
just want to
get my foot in the comedy door and do
something
you know i didn't necessarily want to do
prank because i didn't really
like prank is not my [ __ ] but i was just
funny enough at improv that they were
like
oh he'll be able to write good sketches
and be good on it but um but the show is
[ __ ]
it's such an evil thought to [ __ ] with
people especially because they get
approval from your friends so like
whoever your friends are setting you up
was like
you know but at one point it was like
culturally the thing to be on that
[ __ ] show for something yeah yeah
yeah no for sure i mean
it's great entertainment but i think
ultimately it is [ __ ] and it's
probably why
it's so [ __ ] up but i i'm happy to see
you
like now you're on curb on screen with
ld
himself i was just surprised to see you
in there the character was great too i
loved the
carpenter masterminding the toilet oh
yeah well dude actually i went out for
the original thing i went out for um uh
was a um
and i didn't look aryan enough that's
what larry said um
but i i went out for this guy who ended
up it's a character if you watch the
season
and it's a guy who has a dog named adolf
yeah um
so i went out for that that same day i
went out for that because
larry had said that um the casting
director had known me she had put me in
a few other projects and and jeff
schaefer who directed dave the show that
i'm on right now
loved that show by the way thanks man he
directed a bunch of curbs and
he was like yo you'd be so good for this
this this german guy and i initially
went in with this accent being like
yeah no my parents are from germany but
and it was like a light accent i was
trying to be like a guy
and larry afterwards we improved it and
he loved it but then he was like you
just don't [ __ ] look aryan enough
dude you just look you such a [ __ ]
blue-collar like
irish face you know so he said
he was like i really want to use you but
his character is not at all for you
and um then he goes oh i have an idea i
want to create some
someone to help me design these piss
toilets in
um in the [ __ ] you know larry's latte
or whatever it is
yeah crazily enough schaefer had shown
him
i did a bit on my special about how i
don't think there should be stalls in
bars
because um who's [ __ ] pooping at a
bar like i think
right and it should only be urinals it's
like and if you have to poop you have to
go home like you this
whole bed i do about pooping at the bar
and um
anyway larry had seen it and was like
that's so [ __ ] crazy because we're
crying
we're trying to create this only thing
so when i came in for that i'm sorry it
was the same day
larry was like will you just come knock
this out um
and i came back and we did it and he the
coolest moment two coolest moments of my
career dude genuinely
making him break in in the room making
him break live on camera was
i knew that probably would have happened
because we were just going back and
forth and back and forth but
making him break in the audition room
was huge because i made making him break
and making julia dreyfus break
auditioning for um for veep was probably
the two
of all the things i've done for some
reason those things are just like they
make you feel
so good to make people like that break
who are so
[ __ ] beyond talent i mean you know
yeah yeah dude and she's she is a
comedic
genie like underlying genius i don't
like that word but no one's funnier than
her to me
at living in these little things that
she does she's a [ __ ]
she was killing me dude in the room i
had auditioned for that show
[ __ ] nine times dude she loved me and
the guy
what's his name the [ __ ] foreign guy
that's the ep he just
it never clicked he was like yeah he's
okay like he didn't like the way i
looked which is nine times out of ten is
all it is
so many talented people go out for those
shows that they have the ability but you
don't look like the character they have
in their head
so they just don't it just doesn't work
it's not that like oh you didn't kill it
in the room it's like dude i [ __ ]
wiped the floor but she broke two three
times and she was like get out of here
you're [ __ ]
so anyway but those two moments really
etched out and working with larry was
like you know a dream come true dude i
would have paid them to be on that phone
right
you know well yeah i mean seinfeld is my
first
like comedy love and so
those guys are are gods and you like you
do you like jerry or no
like do you think jesus no i love jerry
but like
um i love jerry i can't i'm saying it's
yeah
his stand up outside of the show like a
lot of people love the show but
he's funny he's funny it's not my
favorite stand-up because his whole
stick
is kind of old school it's like clean
clean
happy no cursing i'm jerry seinfeld i
show up in a suit and i
and and i take this very seriously i
like it but it's not my favorite
style it's just a little old school
that's because
larry is the larry really was seinfeld
well you know they said there's this
great line there's this
wonderful documentary about the making
of it yeah and they say
that you know larry wrote this material
for his
they were friends and larry wrote
material for his girlfriend he didn't
want to perform it though he's like ah
[ __ ] i don't want to
perform it larry was like horrible on
stage a performer
and jerry performed larry's material and
it killed
and so they realized like there was this
amazing combination of
larry's material through jerry's mouth
totally and that yeah that's i mean yeah
that you hear that a lot about guys from
that generation i mean like
robin williams uh he used to [ __ ]
take from people or pay people because
they would write stuff that
he that would come out of his mouth way
better than
he could out of theirs he also notably
historically stole a lot of material
that was kind of he did
yeah a lot of people talk about that in
the comedy world that he stole a lot of
material or he would just say i'm buying
that from you he would go to the club
and
someone would have a bit and he'd be
like here's a hundred bucks i'm buying
that premise or whatever 100 you would
do that a lot
really you could do that he's like hey
dude that's mine
i'm sure they did coke together too i'm
sure they would do a bunch of bloat and
he'd be like okay man that's mine and
then they're like oh [ __ ]
okay wow that's awesome i gotta try that
the coke trap um but yeah he used to
he's notorious for that
robin was like big into like other
people using other people's
material and i don't want to i don't
want to defame him because you know i'm
sure he's
you know he would not like to hear that
but um
you know i don't know i don't know if
he's not doing any more i'm sure he's
no he's not feeling yeah he's not
stealing jokes he's doing his own stuff
on tour right now
i don't know if he's back out on the
road but you never know who's back out
you know um okay this one is this one
if you don't know about this one it's
going to blow your [ __ ] head off
okay tom cruise we all love tom cruise
famous my future husband well liked
one of the first people who got coveted
incidentally he survived he did fine on
it
wait you're talking about tom hanks
aren't you oh my god i am talking about
tom hanks
start over i'm talking about tom hanks
okay
tom cruise wait let me do a new intro
for tom cruise
weirdo scientologist great actor
but very strange
[Laughter]
uh tom hanks on the other hand
beloved by all 100 mr america even
mr worldwide mr worldwide yeah no that's
pitbull dude
the [ __ ] pitbull he's a [ __ ] excuse me
dude
you're talking about you're talking to
pb's number one fan dog i am a pit bull
free i've never missed a show so be
careful how you talk about pb because
that's my
[ __ ] head is what uh oh is that okay
is that wait is that what they call
themselves
that's the fan base i thought you said
pinhead i was like
it's not flattering anyway you know you
probably know that
tom hanks has a son
who looks just like him right yeah
what's his name yeah but did you know he
has another son
named chet no that's who i said that's i
know yeah i know chet hayes yeah chet
haye's the rapper i know him
you know about chad you know about
chet's jamaican
character yeah i saw him and he did it
at the emmys right last year or at the
yeah [ __ ] i wish you didn't know about
this why it works because i don't watch
it i saw you did like a jamaican accent
on
was it bad friends or something else i
mean i do i've done i mean
i do so many [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
accents but you're you're trying you're
trying to do like an irish accent or
something but it sounded jamaican
yeah yeah yeah yeah so that made me
think of chet hanks who's my who like
the fact that this guy exists and is out
there doing this
is just a joy go ahead and play the
first one there in
i mean how embarrassing is this for for
poor thomas on the red carpet
oh man that's how ethan felt he had to
leave it was so hard
i had to turn on the ac it moved you so
much yeah
i got to tell you i have to be honest
with you um
that's the future that liberals want so
if you're if you're scared
that's what they [ __ ] that's what the no
actually i think it's funny that they
defended him his parents were like it's
fun
he's just joshing around his mom
offended him his mom did what's her name
what's the wife
thomas she publicly she rapped like a
week later she went on instagram
google this she was doing like a live
rap because she was trying to like be
supportive
why can't i think of a [ __ ] name
wilson wait is that yeah but look up
oh yeah that's his wife that's that's
his mom look up rio wilson raps or
whatever wait [ __ ] you'll see
he's from a different mom i thought from
a different marriage
oh i have no i mean i don't know well
it's his step step mommy maybe
yeah i think it's his stepmom i think
his mom's jamaican
oh she oh really from the island
what is she from the island of jamaica
because you can be jamaican from like
jamaica queens
so yeah oh that's true yeah i think it's
from jamaica queens issues
i mean like okay i'm not one that really
you know would
screams cultural appropriation or
whatever but i mean like is this race
is this a little bit racist to walk
around always doing this
no because jamaica is an american
territory i think so we're kind of
allowed to do that kind of stuff wait
that's not true
it is now it is not i mean that's why if
i want to do a
cuban accent i can do it because it's a
territory or the us virgin islands if
you want to mock them
i think we can so american samoas yeah
yeah oh i know that yeah if we've
conquered you
or like you owe us a fave we're allowed
to kind of mock you a little bit
you know i haven't thought about it like
that
yeah no i think chet i think what chet
was trying to do
um i think what chet was trying to do
genuinely
was uh i've translated it what he says
he says
uh big up uh which means uh
what's up and then he says uh me father
come
forward manon award which says uh it
means my father
is well deserved and will get a
wonderful award
and then he says uh shout out to the
island which of course means
um hey hi to jamaica
and i just think his home his home where
he's from and born and raised and
you know i think a lot of people today
would say cultural appropriation but i
i would just say you know show me
obama's birth certificate you know how
you know chet
how do you know chet wasn't born in
jamaica you don't know you know what i
mean obama they said he was from [ __ ]
chicago or hawaii it's like which one is
it bud you know so i don't
really believe much anymore it was
proven by the way
oh really dude hawaii yeah it was
are you one of these guys that thinks oh
honestly hawaii is kind of a suspicious
place to be born you know what i mean
you know why they can't find it on a map
so when you fly i think
it's japan um when you fly you're up
there for like six hours and then
they're like oh my god an island up here
and you're like
i don't [ __ ] know dude i am right i
think
you really believe what they tell you
yep well here we have there's a clip of
him ex
here let's see oh this is him trying to
pick up adele in the jamaican accent i
really genuinely think
he thought adele was going to hit him up
yeah play this
adele adele adele
you're not sending me a prayer from a
long time but i often see a picture i
think
it's sweet me i'm gonna tell no lie my
girl
ear style theater be gone yourself
and uh pause it
i will get claimed do you can you
translate that one
yes he did a really good job on the
first one he said uh
he said big up to big up to adele which
means hey what's up adele
right he says
which means uh you've lost a lot of a
significant amount of weight and
wait what you actually heard that or
have you wait no
yeah he said one another which means
you've lost a significant amount of
weight and darn you look good
wait slow it down say that part again
the jamaican part
wanna fit
okay got it and then
um and then at the end he said uh and he
said
uh coming back a family which means uh
which means i'm trying to ruin my
father's life
exactly
what a [ __ ] what did he say at the
very oh he puts on her song and then
does he speak in
in um is he back in james i think it's
yeah there's one where he's trying to
explain big up ethan from h3 the chinese
language there's a clip of him trying to
explain
he goes look do we have this clip ian he
goes look
it's just like most what he's like
snowboarding is just mostly white people
it's just like that oh i do that makes
sense
now when i logged that in i thought no
he said okay he said
he says doing the jamaican accent is
just like most people who snowboard are
white
it's just most people that do the
jamaican accents
people that you're making are black yeah
i guess i understand that like
snowboarders
right well like who's more who's more
likely to eat a croissant for breakfast
a black person or a white person
yeah does that mean black people can't
have them i no certainly not who would
who
would say that an idiot that's why i'm
saying chetanese bro speak some chinese
fluent oh here we've got it yeah
[Laughter]
i love this guy dude yeah he's a legend
we love chat
i got no audio though internet
ton up one more time you know
no watching no fiesta your time soon
come
oh this isn't the one was that a threat
what do you say your time soon come
yeah your time your time no he was
saying that to everyone who's trying to
become an influencer he's saying your
time will soon come saying like
i woke up to the internet going off this
morning saying like a lot of people are
following him and then he says
um then he's basically saying if you're
in the game like i am
and you're trying to be an influencer
like i am your time will come oh i see
very inspirational yeah yeah i mean
honestly
i've spoken i've spoken chet knees now
uh this is my second semester at usc
taking chinese
and um i think i'm doing pretty good the
bummer with that guy
is genuinely this is a mental health
issue
like genuine this is actually like a
mental health because
you know he knows it's stupid to do it
but now he's
done it so long that he's like admitted
he's committed so it's a mental health
issue
but he's unwell yeah he's on well
portugal is it
how do you live in the shadow of a of uh
of woody from toy story it's almost yeah
i mean come on
i think chet told me that chet was like
me fat at one time and not suck along
and i hang that
no no wrap it around the top of that
camera down again and spin it like a
balloon man
right shout out for the island thanks i
want to know what did you make
i want to know how jamaicans feel about
that like i would love to hear from a
jamaican
i have a feeling they're like we don't
sound anything like that you know
they're like this guy i mean maybe they
well actually that's what am i saying
they don't have internet down there they
don't even know what happens you know
they'll never see this um there's one
last thing i wanted to ask you about
yeah you're ticked you know you inspired
me to go on tick tock
i have to say and i love tick tock now
because [ __ ] fun man
because you posting like podcast clips
here and
your own little own little uh
videos and i got on here and i'm having
so much fun
are you scared that trump is gonna kill
tick tock now
um i don't know if i just say this to
your audience or not but i had a
conversation with dt
about it because he so donald and i
are buds i don't even know how to say it
but we're good buds all right and
he calls me every so often and he asked
me about it he was like what should i do
about the talk and i was like brother
leave it alone
and he's like but the goddamn chinese
right and i
and i said i know i know but it's just
such good content and i sent him a
couple of vids from
tiktok and i think he's going to leave
it alone please
would you send him i sent him um
i sent him two different talks i sent
him um charlie dimillio you know the
girl
yeah i sent her doing a pretty basic
terrible white girl thing like
just a dance and uh i was like this has
millions of views you can't take this
away and he was like i don't like it
it's gross and then i was like she's
and he goes i love you save tick tock
thank you so much
single-handedly i called dt and i saved
it it is fun i said i love it
yeah i like dude i used to [ __ ] talk it
for so long
and when i finally got on there and
started doing it i was like
this is great and yeah you know why you
[ __ ] talked it
we both did i bet for the same reason
because we're the same age
and it's something that our generation
is
that's it's not the like the it's i
don't know there's something about it
that you just go
it's just not for me maybe because i
don't follow those kind of trends but
then you see it and you go yes it is
this is just funny well i thought
i thought it was just like underage
girls dancing
because that's kind of no i think i
think that was the beginning and then it
became
my favorite [ __ ] is [ __ ] is is like
watching people take
a clip an audio clip and then do them
doing it you know right
right like i just think that's really
fun have you seen the baba bowies
no oh there's a whole [ __ ] community
of people that just lip sync baba booey
bubba
[ __ ] cracks me up dude when you're
done here go just look up bababoo
it's so stupid those are literally
channels that just
all they make is baba bowie content and
they have like a million followers
it's awesome it's incredible it's so
crazy
and you can't monetize it though right
can you or no uh
well they just create yeah they just
they did this thing the um
the creator fund uh which if you don't
have it enabled you should i mean it's
not much money
but you'll make a little cheddar on the
side i don't have that man i don't
really have i i have
i don't have a lot of i don't even know
i don't really i mean i made like 100
bucks
in like the last 10 days so
you know what i'm saying this is not
exactly life-changing money
dude i say that but someone at home is
like that's i could use 100 [ __ ]
bucks dude yeah
yeah and and we say this and we say this
ethan and i as
multi-multi-multi-multi-millionaires
we don't
and i would walk by and not even look
yeah we're so disconnected with what's
going on dude
i [ __ ] flew here to the studio it's a
mile from my house
yeah and i took a flight dude that's a
little i give a [ __ ] about the common
man baby
you're right if i become super rich i'm
gonna buy an
island and you know how he even had like
this weird little like
altar room it looked like human
sacrifice went down in there do you know
what i'm saying you're talking about
that one building
i just feel yeah well hold on i'm not
done
buying an island i'm gonna buy an island
i'm gonna build a weird
little uh like sacrificial altar
but inside is a nintendo
64 with mario kart and that's all you do
in there
that's tight just bring your homies
and play mario 64. no windows though
no windows i just want black i just want
crazy conspiracy theories
but then when i die or whatever i get
rated by fbi
just to end 64 with mario kart what
about you don't
have goldeneye in there just because i
mean that's you got to have something
else in there you know i mean i think
it's more interesting if it's like the
the only thing found was i mean goldmine
is good i'm not going to dispute you
there though
it's just that's my i mean we've got a
system here in the studio we've got
we've got snes we've got snes
uh and in our snes right now is uh
super mario and there's mortal kombat
over there
um and there's two more games underneath
my dad sent me our snacks me and my
sister
i'm throwing this away i was like it's
original it still works
it still works that's what's up man you
know what i mean they just don't make
them like they used to huh
i know i know the the uh what do they
call this the
ex bothers ex or those they are the
you know xbox xbox they break they get
the red thing the um
red ring of death and uh you know ps
you know the playstation can't get it
together they keep making new ones
that's how shitty they are they're on
like six now because they can't just
stick it out
you know you didn't you didn't have
[ __ ] nintendo 65.
they did it once and they did it right
so amen brother
these companies are [ __ ] dude they
don't know what they're [ __ ] doing
amen you know well andrew yes
it's been uh it's been a joy dude i
loved it
i appreciate you having me on and it's
been it's been really nice to finally
meet you i'm i'm a big fan and and i
think it's fantastic and i'd love to
have you on again dude i appreciate you
and when you i want you to come do bad
friends we actually have um
bobby and i were talking about it we've
just integrated guests because we've got
drop-down paneling so they can be
separate from us and uh you guys are
already bored of each other
no actually we we initially never wanted
guests
and then it just kind of came up if we
were like would it be fun to try
in our 29th episode and then we did and
we liked it a little bit
and now we just want to have on guests
like once in a while that we just really
enjoy you know i mean like i don't we
don't want to fulfill we don't want to
fill guests
um every week because it's just not what
we want to do but um
we were like once in a while it'd be fun
to just have a rant just out of random
like i i just like the idea of just like
week after week no guest and then you
they just get one pop up for fun well i
would be honored i mean i love you guys
both
bobby is uh bobby's great he's awesome
and um yeah i mean it'd be great
um i was watching the clip of the
[ __ ]
the bb gun dude that was the funniest
[ __ ] thing
you know what's so dumb uh as i [ __ ]
brought that into the studio
i knew it was a bad idea yeah you can't
bring that [ __ ] around bobby
no i know well i don't know if you know
he crashed our [ __ ] mobility scooter
i don't know if you ever saw that clip
like he's he's literally just a
psychopath
yeah yeah dude i have to [ __ ] there's
holes in our ceiling in our walls i mean
when we're done with this studio it's in
really bad shape um
two of the doors fell off and one of the
windows is broken right
so we're in trouble when we have to turn
this in the keys
we're gonna have to skip town i'm gonna
have to go to mexico for like a month
yeah well i'll have an island by then
hopefully yeah the 60 what are you gonna
call it by the way
uh rape island oh okay cool we'll just
play nintendo though
yeah uh well bad friends is
i'm happy to see it's doing really good
and it is awesome it's a great podcast
so
thank you please watch that and then i
do whiskey ginger is my own solo one
that i do with like random guests and
uh [ __ ] uh watch us uh
and watch you and then when you come
over to uh our little studio when
everything is good and ready when you
guys feel safe and
or or bring your son if you can your son
do it if you could just set up your kid
and
he can't talk but it would be funny if
bobby pointed a gun at him
yeah i mean i like how you say he can't
talk like that's a
bobby can't write english at all so it's
like
people don't know this is it's really
weird i don't know if i should put this
out to the world but
bobby actually is so um has such bad
broken english that we have to over dub
him that's that's not
actually it's not even his voice no no
he speaks
he means first language is korean
obviously and so we have someone in
come in every week to do kind of a
character voiceover
right that makes sense i mean i didn't
know that put out the original yeah
we should put out the original but but
dude thank you for having me yeah this
was great
i'm i'm uh it's uh it's very cool what
you guys are doing over there is very
funny
and zach um stopped faking it with the
guitars ian yep
get your life together dan i will see
you at the manhole tonight
sick dude see you then thank you man i
appreciate it
all right guys later bye dude thank you